with millions of us encouraged to stay
home because of the pandemic
many people playfully predicted a baby
boom at the nine-month mark
but it could be a baby bust instead with
all the fear and the uncertainty both of
cobit and
the economy many people were thinking of
having a baby now they just put those
plans on hold
and those who don't want to get pregnant
are being extra cautious
well nurex is the largest digital
practice for women's health and they saw
a
50 percent increase in requests for
birth control prescriptions when the
pandemic hit back in march
and also a 40 increase in demand for the
morning after pill
everything from financial security or
insecurity
truthfully as well as
you know fears around having to go into
the hospital and giving birth during
this time so
you know it's it's a whole host of
reasons that we believe are underlying
this increase in demand for
contraception
there are lots of studies that prove a
direct link between an economic downturn
and birth rates going all the way back
to the great recession
now a decade ago states where the
recession was the most
severe experience the most the largest
drop
in births now researchers at the
brookings institution have forecasted
there could be
a half million fewer babies born in this
country this year
for